SPEAKER 1: I first met our next
speaker and his lovely wife,
Penny, way back in the last
decade of the last century.
If that sounds like a
long time ago, it is.
It was.
At the time, I was studying
for my PhD in political science
at the Claremont
Graduate School,
and he was the president
of the Claremont Institute.
And what I quickly learned
about him is something
Hillsdale students
today learn about him,
and that's the fact
that he's a teacher.
He's always teaching.
He didn't teach formal
classes back then,
but he always took the time to
talk to us graduate students.
And by the way, last night I
mentioned his love of tennis.
His love of teaching
extended to the tennis court.
We used to play
with some regularity
back in those long-ago days.
He was well-skilled in the
fundamentals of the game,
and he loved to teach
those fundamentals.
Now, what that meant in practice
is that, not only would he
trounce you on the
court, afterwards he
would explain exactly
how he trounced you.
[LAUGHTER]
I would encourage you
to come and see us
on the Hillsdale campus,
and what you'll see
is he hasn't changed a bit.
He still loves to teach and now
he's doing it in the classroom.
He offers courses on
a variety of subjects,
including Aristotle, the
Constitution, CS Lewis,
and totalitarian novels.
And it's been my
privilege to work
with him at my alma
mater for the past, now,
more than 20 years.
Please welcome
back to the podium,
the 12th President of Hillsdale
College, Larry P. Arnn.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY P. ARNN: Well, I
thought Mark Steyn was
going to end up giving the
best speech at this thing,
but now there's doubt.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you all for being here.
I'm going to excuse myself
after lunch because I'm
having lunch with the governor.
[APPLAUSE]
And that's happening because
I'm a really important guy.
[LAUGHTER]
That's happening because he's
wanting to save the country,
and he wants charter schools,
and we know a lot about that.
[APPLAUSE]
And I've had a new
thought in the last month
that I'll tell you about.
For some reason, we
have education centers
popping up all over the place,
and we didn't really plan them.
Well, we did one in Washington,
DC, on Capitol Hill.
We got a graduate school there
and a lot going on there.
But there's one in
Somers, Connecticut now.
That's on the
Massachusetts border.
Have you heard about that?
It was given to us by
the founder and builder
of Friendly Ice Cream.
And it's a beautiful property,
and it has an exact replica
of Monticello on it.
And I thought, OK.
And he called up
and said, I'm going
to give you this property, and
I want to give you $25 million
in endowment to take care of it.
[APPLAUSE]
And I looked around
for a minute--
couldn't think of
a reason to say no.
[LAUGHTER]
Now there's something
like that in California--
maybe two things.
And then the other
day, I was reading
about our governor in Michigan.
[CROWD BOOING]
And I thought, you
know, California,
Connecticut, Michigan?
We need to go to a red state.
So we may--
I'm going to talk to
the governor about that.
And see, it'll be a great
conversation for him,
because I'm confident--
other governors have
done this when I bring it up.
Well, we'll help you.
Kristi Noem offered to build
us an entire campus in South
Dakota.
And I said, Governor, we
don't take any money from you.
We can't do that.
She said, well, maybe
I could raise it.
Maybe, I said, but
that would be a lot.
So I don't want anything
from the governor
except to talk to him about
it and ask him to anticipate
what's going to happen.
And I'll tell you what we're
going to do in these education
centers.
We now have accumulated
registered online students,
about three and 1/2 million.
We have 26 charter schools
and eight more opening
in the next 18 months.
[APPLAUSE]
We've got curricula
and we've got schools
that we advise in
the running of.
And we have hundreds
of teachers come
to our campus in the
summer, and we're getting
to know a lot about that.
And so we're going to open
a homeschool division.
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to do online
courses for credit.
It means you'll
actually have to study.
And first,
dual-enrollment courses.
We're going to start
a master's degree
program in classical
education pretty soon,
I think, so that we
can staff these schools
because the great bottleneck
is headmasters, and after that,
teachers.
And teaching is a
very high calling.
And they're not trained that
way anymore, and that's too bad.
So these education centers will
be where those people can come
somewhere local
and do in-person--
like this, sort of.
And so it's a grand
adventure, and that's
why I won't be here
at lunch today.
Now, this crisis that we're in--
that's a good segue into that,
right, because this is the
most serious kind of thing,
in my opinion.
How do we understand it?
What is it?
And then what do we do about it?
And I'll mention some examples
from the past that give hope.
Think of the resources
that are gathered
by the ruling class, because
that's what they are now.
The institutions
in which we learn,
starting with the
most elite ones, where
the fancypants
people are trained,
they are almost
entirely woke now.
Williams College-- I
have a friend there,
teaches in political science.
And he wrote an article in Aero
Magazine, "The Woke Movement
at Williams College."
You can look it up.
Aero is A-E-R-O.
It's free online.
It's a terrifying thing.
Basically, school has stopped
happening because everybody's
afraid to say anything.
But that's just at the top
because the staple university
in America today
is of two kinds.
The modal type, the one that's
most common, it's either
a second or third-tier
state university, where
almost everybody
goes to college now,
or else it's a broke
liberal-arts college.
And I think Forbes says
there are 963 of those
and that maybe 30% of
them are in some kind
of imminent trouble.
And what happens at
those state universities
is that they're clones
of the most elite
to the best of their ability--
and very common, that is.
It's the third-tier ones,
and second-tier ones some,
that train the teachers,
and they are teaching
them all the rightest stuff.
And they're heavily
under the influence
of the state
education bureaucracy
in every state which
is, by the way,
more than half the
budget in every state.
And I'll mention about that,
that in the public schools
in America--
this is a shocking fact,
and nobody talks about it.
Did you know that more
than half the employees
in public education
today are not teachers?
Do you know what the number
is in a charter school?
It's about six teachers for
every non-teaching employee.
So first of all, more
than half the budget
never gets anywhere
near the school.
And what do those people do?
Well, they design
what's to be taught.
You know, like that needs
to be done, by the way.
I mean, if the one in this room
who knows the least about it
set out honestly to
construct a basic curriculum
along the
long-established lines,
you would do it more or less
successfully in about a month.
It's not that hard, right?
Human beings grow up at about
the same rate they always did.
They need to know
the same things.
They need to be good at
the human skills-- reading,
writing, and arithmetic.
They need natural
history, natural science,
and the story of human
beings, and literature
and philosophy and history.
And then you've done it, right?
That's everything.
But no.
Constantly inventing new
ways to teach them to read,
for example.
Whereas in our charter schools,
in our Hillsdale Academy,
we've never graduated
a kindergartener
who couldn't read.
And the reason is they
can already read--
I mean, in principle.
Because my granddaughter,
that makes me pity you,
she's already teaching
herself to talk.
And she's going to
be like her mother.
She's never going to shut up.
[LAUGHTER]
But then once you talk--
because what happens
when you talk?
You say, glasses.
There are many pairs
of glasses, right?
And we don't look at
cue cards or flash cards
to learn what that is or to see
a whole variety of them, right?
We just look at it, and we
can see the essence of it.
And then that word,
glasses, that's
the equivalent of the
mark that's on a page--
G-L-A-S-S-E-S.
And so all you got
to do-- the reason
it works is because
they've already
taught themselves the sounds.
That's why phonics works, right?
Just apply phonics to
the marks on the page.
And the point is,
a lot of them just
discover that for
themselves, by the way.
But even if they
don't, just teach them
what the sounds are that
go with these letters.
And you know what?
I can't do it.
But I actually did do
phonics in elementary school,
and that was in the
late-17th century.
[LAUGHTER]
So the point is there's
a huge load in this.
And by the way,
their opinions tend
to be opinions that would
justify their existence.
You see, like a history
teacher or a science teacher
or a lit teacher, they'll
be doing that because they
think that those subjects are
important and they love them.
Whereas if you're a
regulator of education,
you're bound to think education
needs a lot of regulating.
And what's wrong, by the
way, with that idea--
I said it this morning
to the first-timers.
If you become a teacher--
I didn't do it until I was 47.
My father was a high
school teacher in Arkansas,
and he was a wonderful man,
and he found his happiness
doing that.
Never made any money.
But I started doing it when I
decided to go into the college
business, and my
first job in a college
is the one I've got today.
And I started teaching.
And a great truth that
I knew only in principle
was borne in upon me.
And that is, you
don't teach them.
They learn.
You just help them.
And if you explain to them the
most beautiful thing you know--
something that might have taken
you years of devotion and love
to learn--
if you don't do it
right way, you'll
just bore the heck out of them.
And the way not to do that is to
ask them before you tell them.
It's good to tell them why
this might be important.
But what is that thing?
That's Socrates' question,
that he's always asking--
[GREEK] What is?
What is this?
What is that?
Right?
Well, education is this
control of a vast engine that
obscures that fact, and
therefore dehumanizes
the kids in a more
general and less intense
way than making them
transgender when
they're too young to decide.
Now, large parts of the way we
gather and report information
is in concentrated hands--
an element, I think,
of this ruling class.
I think that what college
professors have done--
because, you know, being
a college professor,
it ain't sexy by today's terms.
I can tell you what they are.
I've interviewed
more than 450 people
for faculty jobs in 21 years.
I just love it.
I've just learned to
respect them so deeply.
And here's the thing.
They're all used to being among
the smartest people they ever
met.
[LAUGHTER]
They are, you know?
And they could go to
law school or med school
and there'd be a guaranteed
path to a big income.
And they don't.
They get three times
as much education
and they're going to
make a third as much.
Now why do they
make that choice?
The good ones-- and the
ones at Hillsdale are good--
there's a love.
They love.
They want to know.
They too, see, they carry their
excellence inside themselves.
There's a fire that burns in
them to get them all that way.
And then they want to teach.
Well, the trouble is,
you'll never get rich,
and you don't really get to
tell anybody adult what to do.
So what if-- and this
is a great engineering
project that was born
in the Progressive Era
in American universities.
It came from Germany--
we could be the ones who would
plan the future of society.
Now we will rule.
See, we'll be important.
We'll be powerful.
I once stayed in the suburbs
outside Washington, DC
and went in on the metro.
And I just looked who was there.
And I recognized a
couple of people,
and I asked a couple of
others who they were.
And they were academics going
in to decide what the government
was going to do today.
And that's kind of
intoxicating and strong.
Men and women of affairs, right?
So they dominate journalism now.
And see, journalists are
just like college professors
because what they used to be
was servants of the truth.
That speech that we just heard--
I just invited
Abigail to come teach
because it was disciplined.
And what was it disciplined to?
The facts as she has seen them.
And in the course of it,
she named a whole bunch
of things that were curious to
me, but sounded very plausible.
Like, for example,
there are a lot
of people who have
gender dysphoria.
And I've never doubted
that, and I've never doubted
they shouldn't have help.
But it's possible
that this could even
be help to some people, and
you shouldn't begrudge that.
And that means that she
followed what she saw.
And that means she's not
master of the universe.
She's just beholding it.
And this new temper is better.
It's all a contest for power.
And journalists today,
they go look at things
and they report them.
That's what they're
supposed to do.
And they have to struggle
to do it objectively
and they got to take care.
It's just like the
scholar's art except it's
stuff that's moving every day.
Well, what if, instead,
they get to decide
who's the next president
of the United States?
That's a cool station.
The Washington Post really
writes these the most.
If you read the
stories about who
gets to go to the White
House press conference,
you can tell the
high journalists
think they own that space.
That's our space, you see?
And they're the media.
They're between
us and something.
And we can't have direct
access to that something.
That's the phenomenon.
And I liked it that Trump would
pick nobodies to come in there.
It really ticked them off, see?
[LAUGHTER]
But that space,
that's a space that
belongs to the American
people, and it's
reserved for the
person they elect
to be the chief executive.
But no, these guys
own that space now.
It's like a bigger deal--
power.
The major corporations.
Did you know, this stuff
that went on in the last few
months-- and it's
going on all the time--
threatening this
state, for example,
right now about a
transgender law.
Well, two years ago, I
think it was, Bezos and Tim
Cook and the whole
gang, they actually
have more money
than everybody else,
if you include
their money in that.
[LAUGHTER]
And they decided that
they would renounce
what was called the Friedman
Rule, from Milton Friedman.
And the Friedman Rule was, the
assets of a public corporation
belong to the
shareholders, and they
should be used for the purpose
of enhancing shareholder value.
And if they want to give to
charity, give their own money,
and give the charity money
back to the shareholders.
And they just specifically
renounced that.
And that means what
they were saying,
in the plainest
language, was, we're
going to take other
people's money now,
and we're going to decide
how to affect the society.
Power, you see?
Power.
I think Steve Jobs is
probably a great man,
and I think the ones who
follow him are not so great.
But one of the
reasons was he always
thought he was conforming to the
demands of beauty and utility
in making his products.
And he was very
disciplined about that.
Well, that means that all acts
of creativity of high worth
are also great
acts of obedience.
It's obedience we
don't like anymore.
We like to tell
people what to do.
Did you know that obedience
was one of Winston Churchill's
favorite words?
He always thought
he was obeying.
That's why he was so stubborn.
[LAUGHTER]
Then there's the
regulatory state,
and that's 24 million
people, most of them
at the state level.
But it's very much a system that
influences from the top down.
And they're a class of person.
And they're not what
they used to be.
Churchill said that
famous thing once--
no longer civil and
no longer servants.
Well, there's that going on.
In the early Progressive Era--
RJ Pestritto
publishes about that;
he's the dean of our graduate
school in the politics
department--
they thought that separation
of powers was no longer needed
because now there's going to
be a class of person working
in the government who will have
a guaranteed salary that cannot
be reduced, it'll be
enough to support them,
and they'll have tenure
in office forever.
And that means they won't
have any needs or interest,
and so they won't pursue their
needs and interest in politics.
If you look at the list of the
10 biggest givers in politics
today, in partisan
elections, all on one side,
the public employee
unions are tops.
Because they're people too,
and they have interests,
and they like a world in which
people like them decide things
in the name, not of consent--
the popular thing-- in
the name of science.
The pandemic is the craziest
thing in the world to me
because we decided
we were going to have
college, up to the point
of threat of arrest,
which I've had.
But I didn't want to
do that recklessly.
As I tell the students,
if you get sick
and die, although
we can get more,
it'll be very
inconvenient to me.
[LAUGHTER]
I say that all the time.
You know, it's a weird
thing at Hillsdale College.
The mothers like that.
[LAUGHTER]
They're like Spartan women.
Anyway, I didn't
want them to die.
Disrupt the schedule.
And so I tried to find
out, and we found ourselves
in association with
some people that I
think are just geniuses--
Jay Bhattacharya, Scott
Atlas, Daniel Halperin.
[APPLAUSE]
Then after that, it's easy
because I have to obey the law,
if they actually make a law--
although what they make now
is memos from the governor,
and that's not really how
a law gets made, you know.
And those can be
challenged in court,
and we are ready to do it.
But did I tell you this?
We have these doctors
from the Mayo Clinic,
and the Mayo Clinic is very
cautious about the coronavirus
and they're worried about the
long-term effects and all that.
And they always
say, are you worried
about the long-term effects?
And I said, no, I'm busy.
I got a lot to do.
[LAUGHTER]
But anyway, we can't
know that, right?
It's exactly like the point
made earlier about reversibility
of some of these things.
Well, it hasn't been long
enough to know, right?
Well, anyway, one of them
was kind of critical of me.
Well, he's a
friend, but he said,
you really picked the experts
that were for opening up.
And I said, sure.
And he said, oh.
He was surprised I'd admit that.
And I said, look,
doc, are you guys
the tops in the world
at the Mayo Clinic?
And he said, yeah,
we're pretty good.
And I said, how about
these guys at Stanford?
Are they OK?
Expert knowledge--
this ruling class
operates in the
name of expertise.
And that's a different
title to rule than consent,
the consent of equal souls.
And this expertise has got
to be strictly limited.
As Winston Churchill
explained, expert knowledge
is narrow knowledge.
Imagine one of those sets
of parents and the kid
comes under this gender thing.
What are you going to do?
That's a really hard decision.
Because you're going to
stand up to a lot of people,
and they're powerful, and
they might take your kid.
Or you're going to leave the kid
there and try to cope with it.
There's no good answer
to that question.
But nobody is better
qualified to make the judgment
than a mother.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to give you some
instances where things have
been like this, where
everything was at stake
and we might lose our freedom.
And one of them is in 1948--
1945 to 1951.
After the Second World
War, the socialists
came in, big majority.
And they're not like these
guys that we've got today.
They had been announcing
for 50 years what
they were going to do, and
then they won a big majority.
And Churchill
always said that it
would be the death of
civilization and freedom,
but, by golly, they're
entitled to do it.
And so what we're going
to do is complain about it
and then reverse it later.
And his campaign-- this is a
key thing that I want to say
today--
from 1945 to 1952,
Winston Churchill
led the Conservative Party on
a campaign against socialism
under the title "Socialism
Versus The People."
You see?
And he would point out to them
that practical decisions always
involve a hundred factors.
And by the way, we make them
every day, every one of us.
There's no more intense or
practical or consequential
decision than how
to raise your kid.
Well, Mr. Douglas Jay
of the Home Office
in the Attlee socialist
administration
said a famous thing.
And it echoes now.
If you know anything about
modern British history,
you'll know this.
He said, mothers do
not always understand
how to feed their children.
The gentlemen in Whitehall--
that's the governing center
of Britain--
the gentlemen in
Whitehall know better.
And he made the terrible
mistake of saying
that in the hearing
of Winston Churchill.
[LAUGHTER]
And Churchill rang
the changes on that.
But you see what that means?
I just named a
four-part, vast apparatus
that is working together
and that controls, directly
and indirectly, more than half
of the economy in the United
States and Europe.
That is a formidable force.
It's huge.
And how are you
going to stop it?
And it's proceeding
under the principle
that you can't teach a kid
to read without expertise,
which is stupid.
Because first of
all, a lot of them
learn to read on their own.
And so that's the point.
That's, by the way,
why it will eventually
become ugly and despotic,
despite kind intentions.
Because this is the thing
that has to justify itself,
and it's furiously at
work on that all the time.
This happened in 1776, in 1860,
in 1945 in Britain, and in 1979
in Britain.
Things were as bad as this
in all those occasions.
Now, I'm not going to
talk a lot about Russia
in 1917 because that's
a counterexample.
In other words, the Russian
Revolution succeeded,
and it succeeded by
heartbreakingly narrow margins.
And the lives of a
hundred-million people were
at stake, and they lost
their lives because of that--
well, at world communism.
Russia was not as good
at killing as China.
It was maybe 35
million in Russia.
And so that's a sad one, right?
But those won the American
Revolution, the Civil War,
the rise of Margaret
Thatcher in Britain,
and the post-war Churchill--
only time he became prime
minister, in 1951--
and his combat
against socialism.
Which, by the way, that
1951 to '55 administration
got rid of part of socialism,
and Margaret Thatcher
got rid of the rest.
And I'll tell you what
those things have in common.
First of all, a
movement started.
Notice how many people
are in this room?
Last night, people would
say, but the American people
accept this now.
Why is there no
movement against it?
And to both of them
I said, look around.
I mean, I'm telling you.
We at the college, whatever
line of operation we're in--
admissions, faculty hiring,
events, charter schools,
online students-- we can't
beat them off with a stick.
And it makes a person
optimistic when he sees that.
Because we have this big
national mess that we've made,
but it all radiates from
a tight, little world
that we're all in,
and we get to measure
the effects of what we do and
say before our eyes every day.
It's just so fine and such a
grand thing to be able to do.
And it helps a lot.
It makes it better, we think.
So there's a movement.
And the next part is greatness--
some great leader.
And that's extremely
unpredictable.
In the classic
works, statesmanship,
which is a form of art--
a very difficult form of
human making, or art--
is understood as a
synonym for chance.
In Churchill's
writing, very often,
because chance is the
intersection of two causes
that produce a third
result that neither of them
would have produced on its own.
And two independent
causes, right?
So if snow gets on the
branch, the branch breaks off.
That's nature.
Saw off the branch.
That's art.
Saw off the branch on the
top of the head of somebody
standing below.
That's either chance
or a misdemeanor.
[LAUGHTER]
And so, why would you think
that these extremely rare
and artful people
would also be chance?
Well, the reason is, can't
control when they show up
and sometimes you
really need them.
Now would be good.
But they didn't
make the movements.
Those started because
people saw something
and it disturbed them.
Nobody was worried about Great
Britain before 1763 in America.
But then they won the
big war with France,
and they've got this
whacking big empire,
and it just comes to them,
maybe we ought to use it.
And then just so
happens over there,
they had a terrible
failure of statesmanship.
Because the great men in
Britain at that time--
Edmund Burke and William Pitt--
were friends of the
American Revolution.
No, they were governed by
Lord North, who was an idiot.
But they started
doing things to people
who'd been governing
themselves for 150 years,
and they didn't like it.
And then there was a
kind of an ignitor.
Tom Paine wrote Common Sense.
Before that, George Whitfield,
who's the greatest preacher,
probably.
He was the Billy Graham
of the 18th century,
and he would get 30,000 people
to come and hear him preach.
And he was preaching about
faith, but also freedom.
And he became big friends
with Ben Franklin,
who was not
particularly orthodox
in his Christian views.
[LAUGHTER]
And they became friends,
because Ben Franklin went.
And he said, no way he
can talk to 30,000 people.
And so he went and
stood by the stage.
And he walked away
and counted his paces
until he could just barely
hear him, but could hear him.
And then he measured--
you know, Ben Franklin
was kind of a lunatic.
I mean, a very great man,
but he was very meticulous.
He measured the space.
And how many people
could stand in the space?
30,000.
Now, those things were sort
of catalysts, or ignitors.
But then somebody came
along to guide all of that.
And you know, don't think that
the situation is more difficult
now than it was in 1776.
A people who had never
had an army, never
had a government
of their own, were
about to make war on the
greatest power on Earth.
People say to me
sometimes, we could never
have a great revival like
we had in 1858 to 1860
because people don't pay
attention to politics.
30,000 people came to listen
to the Lincoln-Douglas debates,
and I urge you to read them.
They're sublime.
Douglas is very artful
and very powerful.
Lincoln is sublime, and
he destroyed Douglas.
And yeah, 30,000 people--
they went on three and 1/2,
four hours--
each one.
There were eight of them.
And then they came on their
horses and they sat in the sun.
And they say, people
haven't done that since.
Well, I said, you know, they
never did that before either,
but something important
was going on, right?
This slavery thing was
extremely troubling.
And from every point of view--
the wicked ones who
thought that they deserved
to own the slaves,
they were afraid they
were going to lose it.
But really what they were afraid
of was they couldn't expand it.
And others, for a mixture of
reasons, the sublime of which
is equality and
freedom, but also mixed
around that we don't really
want a lot of Black people
in this state.
And that's the cauldron that
Abraham Lincoln stood up.
And he was a shabby lawyer.
Everybody thought he was a
hobo when they first saw him.
And Stephen Douglas
dressed in ruffled shirts
and had matched horses
on his carriage.
He just looked like the
aristocracy coming to town.
And see, people listen
to those arguments.
That's happening more and more.
In 1948, Churchill
raised that campaign.
And he was a one-man wrecking
ball in the House of Commons.
He could just do amazing things.
He, by himself,
built the movement
that got Britain to rearm just
barely enough to survive 1940.
And at first, he had
five or six backbenchers
who were in disrepute and
they were the only ones
who listened to him.
But he was very
good at what he did.
People kept writing him.
He started a group
called The Focus.
And the purpose of
it was, we're not
going to fight with each
other about anything else.
We're going to unite.
I mean, we can be socialist,
and we can be capitalist,
we can be whatever.
We're going to
agree that we have
to stop Adolf Hitler from
conquering Great Britain.
That's all.
Well, there were
hundreds of thousands
of people in that thing.
And it just grew from nowhere.
It got no help from
the BBC because just
remember what I said
about learning to read
and about teaching?
The salvation of the
United States of America
is in each citizen, and
we're going to find out
if they're still Americans.
And if they're not,
it's already over.
But I think they are.
And they are going to
produce the conditions
for a turnaround, or else those
conditions won't be produced.
Margaret Thatcher-- I happened
to be living there at the time.
I went over there
to get my girl.
By the way, I was very
relieved that it's
rare for women in their 50s
and 60s to go transgender.
[LAUGHTER]
I told Penny that, and she said,
we should ask her about men.
[LAUGHTER]
I was working on the official
biography of Winston Churchill.
And you know, that was great.
But then Margaret
Thatcher became the leader
of the Conservative Party, and
then prime minister in 1979,
right in the middle of the time
that I was living there with my
soon to be Mrs. And it was
just the most thrilling thing
you ever saw.
I like tennis.
And so we were there, and
we'd watch Wimbledon on TV.
That was the McEnroe
versus Borg years.
And this was better.
Margaret Thatcher arguing
with James Callaghan,
the socialist prime minister.
And the adjective they
used for her was shrill.
She's shrill, right?
Well, she's a woman.
She didn't sound like a man.
But Lord, what she
wasn't was shrill.
She was tough.
And then she broke him down.
And he, by the way, was
the last great taunter
of Winston Churchill,
early in Callaghan's career
and late in Churchill's career.
And so he's pretty
formidable, right?
And she took him
down and broke him.
And then what was
their situation?
It's as bad as this.
First of all, the Labour Party
had a majority and they were
ruled by the Trade
Unions Council,
a majority of whom were open
members of the Communist Party.
And then these labor unions
were extremely strong
and they would shut down
parts of the country.
They'd make a demand, very
often on the government,
because there were
still some socialized--
the railroads and the phone
company and some of those--
and they'd just demand
what they wanted.
And then in the winter,
they'd stop communication.
You couldn't get milk.
And they would picket, not only
a company they were in dispute
with.
It was picketing private people,
the government, everybody.
But they'd picket their
customers and suppliers too,
called secondary picketing.
And Edward Heath,
who was a weenie, who
was elected prime minister
before Margaret Thatcher,
he had promised to stop
this if he got a majority.
And he got a majority,
and he didn't stop it.
And he gave in to the unions
in the middle of the winter.
People were getting cold.
So she says she
won't do that, right?
And she gets elected.
And I can remember the day.
I was watching the news
because they had shut down
a part of Yorkshire, up in
the north, the city of York,
an area of it where
there was an industry
and a lot of different
companies working together.
And they just closed
the whole thing down
and the city wasn't working.
And the BBC is there reporting.
And then the reporter heard
something and he looked.
And he said, oh,
there's a convoy coming.
And it was buses and trucks.
And what was in the
buses was London cops.
And what was in the trucks
was portable fencing.
And they arrested
about 5,000 people.
[LAUGHS] And they put them
in these fences they built.
And then that was over.
And then the next day,
the BBC was showing guys
in dark suits and briefcases
going to union offices
to seize their assets.
And you know, by 5
o'clock the next day,
there were negotiations
going on about this.
And she is the firmest
example of executive action
I've seen with my own eyes.
Not more form-- I was privileged
to know her pretty well.
And I was privileged
to know Ronald Reagan.
And I'd always say to
him, Mr. President--
because I was sometimes
critical of him, to him--
and I'd say, Mr.
President, you're
the greatest man I ever met.
And he would remember
and say, yeah,
but you think
Margaret's greater.
And I'd say-- [SHRUGS]
[LAUGHTER]
What is to happen today?
Well, both options-- just
like in all of these crises
I've named--
remember, there was
a movement, and there
was somebody to guide and
lead it, and it became clear,
and it was fought through--
sometimes with
violence, sometimes not.
Well, once you see that that's
a kind of pattern, that's
what's happened in the
past, first of all,
you understand this
is very formidable.
Because for most of the
American Revolution and most
of the Civil War, most
of the Second World War--
a different kind of crisis but,
by the way, similar forces--
the people who
eventually won couldn't
imagine that they could win.
They thought they were
fighting to the death, you see.
And that means that we
may have to undergo that.
But we should take comfort from
things like this, because--
and this is my final point--
freedom is a beautiful thing.
The Constitution of the United
States is a beautiful thing.
The Declaration
of Independence is
the most beautiful political
document ever written.
And in the first line
of Aristotle's Ethics,
he says that every
choice we make
and every action we take
and every inquiry we
take all seem to
aim at some good.
And the highest form of
the good is the beautiful.
We all long for that.
These things that
they're doing now,
they're dangerous
because they parade
in the name of the beautiful.
But if they're not
beautiful, that can't last.
And that means, just like in
every kid there's the potential
to read, in every human being
breast there's the potential
to fight for freedom.
The thing to do now is to
communicate to everyone
you know--
learn, get better, teach.
Don't make yourself a nuisance.
Well, later that might be right.
[LAUGHTER]
One of the iron rules
in excellent education
is you can't teach
people who don't
want to learn because it's
hard for them, you know?
And that means,
don't annoy people.
Make it easy.
If you see something
lovely that you
want people to read, send
it to some people and say,
you probably don't have time to
read this, but I found it good.
And then you're not
challenging them.
I get a lot of recommendations
like that, and sometimes
with a challenge.
Sometimes people
write, well, if you're
really serious about your
job, then-- you know?
[LAUGHTER]
And I usually write
back, I'm not.
[LAUGHTER]
See, just like it's true--
the thing about a
despotic movement,
they always know who their
numbers are because everybody's
sort of bought and paid for.
Whereas a free movement,
it's of infinite size,
as many as there are people.
When Abraham Lincoln called for
75,000 troops in March of 1861,
he didn't know if they'd come.
He did know that there was
a hostile army that almost
had the Capital surrounded.
And if Maryland seceded-- and it
was about to-- then Washington,
DC would be encircled.
He knew that.
And he didn't know if
there could be any help.
Well, that's where
we are too, remember.
Because we're on the free side.
And that means people who
are free will join us,
or else they will not.
Let's get them to.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Now I want to tell those
of you in the front
that many of those people
in the back were standing up
and you were not.
If you didn't like
my speech, get out.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
We now have time
for a few questions.
If you would like
to ask a question,
please come find your
way to a microphone.
Question to the speaker's left.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Arnn,
thank you so much.
Thanks for the invitation.
We are first-timers.
We're so glad to be here.
And I'm so glad you mentioned
Mrs. Thatcher and President
Reagan.
Last week, I started to
use one of his quotes
as my new signature block--
"The future doesn't belong
to the faint-hearted.
It belongs to the brave."
LARRY P. ARNN: That's it.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
See, the two great
talks we've heard so far
had many things in common,
and one of the best was,
speak your piece.
This not wanting to be rude--
you shouldn't be rude,
but you shouldn't
be afraid of being called rude.
And that means, if
somebody is doing something
that you think is disastrous,
there's only two cures.
And one of them is
to argue with them,
and the other is to shoot
them, and arguing with them
is a lot better.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And I'm wearing
Rush Limbaugh's tie.
LARRY P. ARNN: You're
wearing-- yeah.
SPEAKER 2: Question to
the speaker's right.
AUDIENCE: Sir, you've
got a lot to say there,
but there's one concern I have.
Right now, if you speak
up, you stand alone.
And that's a very
dangerous place to be,
because our government
could just grab you up.
So what do we do?
LARRY P. ARNN: Well, first
of all, I envy that beard.
[LAUGHTER]
I bet you get a lot of girls.
Just one.
You got one.
Yeah, that's what I got.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not the same one,
I don't think, though.
So the thing is, yeah,
in the beginning.
But last summer--
I'm afraid it's going to
be as bad this summer.
Last summer, all these
events started unfolding,
and I think that
they're connected.
And I think that the pandemic
policies, which I think
are absurd and have
cost many lives--
whereas if we had identified
and focused on the--
that's what the Great Barrington
Declaration calls for, right?
And it just seems
so sensible to me,
especially if you
take into account
the fact that people shouldn't
have to shut their businesses
and stay home.
And you have the
right to assemble.
What about that?
Anyway.
And then that led to,
then, the race riots,
and then the election.
And those are violent
things and terrible things
and the pressures were enormous.
And so Doug Jeffrey,
who's external affairs
at the college and my
longest serving colleague--
pity him-- what did we do on
Imprimis except the pandemic
and the race riots
and the election?
And nobody else was doing that.
And so I thought, OK, we're
going to be destroyed.
We did it anyway.
I could give you a list
of the [INAUDIBLE]..
Everybody got petitions up--
social media movements that
you have to make a statement.
So we had a bunch
of them do that.
And we don't answer statements.
If somebody gives me a petition,
before I open it I say,
well, I'll read this
if you want me to.
But I promise, whatever
you're asking me to do,
I'm going to do the opposite.
You want me to read it?
Anyway.
And we don't answer them, right?
Well, I got ticked off about the
one about Black Lives Matter.
The thing that got
me was they said
they were coasting on the
experience of the founders
of the college, and we've got
to stop talking about them now.
So we answered that.
And David Whalen-- he's
a very talented man--
he wrote most of that.
And it was awesome
and they printed it
in the Wall Street Journal.
And then I had
college presidents
from all over the country
write me and praise that.
And every time I thought,
and where were you?
So the point is
somebody has to start.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'm a
Hillsdale grandparent,
so this is my first
time to be here.
But I was a classroom
teacher for 41 years--
a teacher, not an educator.
I really get tired of everybody
being described as educators.
I feel like I was a teacher.
And that's all I ever wanted
to do, was teach chemistry.
I loved my students.
LARRY P. ARNN: You just
said a lot of information
about yourself.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
want to know what's
your opinion about
educators versus teachers,
since you describe
yourself as a teacher.
LARRY P. ARNN:
We're all teachers.
My dad was a teacher.
And by the way, you
know what the verb
that they use for teaching
in the core curriculum--
in all curriculum talk--
teaching is called delivery.
And the point is, teachers
are now like conveyor belts.
Somebody prepares a package.
You don't really even
have to know what's in it.
Just take it down there
and give it to that guy.
That's the model.
And it's devastating
and it's demeaning.
So, in the great Western movies,
there's often a schoolteacher.
And the cowboys take their hats
off when they go in the school
and they're polite
around the teacher.
And the teacher is a symbol
of wisdom in the society,
and often functions, in the
film, to supply knowledge.
We always had girls
at Hillsdale College,
and you had to know Greek and
Latin to get into the college
back then.
Our standards have slipped.
[LAUGHTER]
And they had a prep school
to teach those things.
What happened to those women?
They all became teachers, of
their families and everybody
in their region.
And they functioned
as the wisest people
and most knowledgeable
people on the scene.
Well, now they're
delivery boys and girls.
And that's just
devastating demotion.
And some of them--
we notice, if you want to get
a job at Hillsdale College,
do not ever manifest
this point--
some of them take pride
that they wrote curricula
that other people had to follow.
And we write curricula for
15,000 or 20,000 students
who are studying all the
time, but we write it
with the teachers.
So yeah, good point.
SPEAKER 2: Question to
the speaker's right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Dr. Arnn.
I'm a homeschool mom of
seven, and my first three
are at Hillsdale.
LARRY P. ARNN: Mm.
[APPLAUSE]
What is your name?
AUDIENCE: Randi Moody.
LARRY P. ARNN: Oh, Moody, yeah.
I'm sorry, I threw
those three out.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I understand why.
I did too.
But homeschooling is a
countercultural thing to do
and very difficult.
So my question
is, what would you
say to encourage
the homeschool movement?
LARRY P. ARNN: Oh, man.
Now, is Dan Peters here--
the trustee?
You in the room, Dan?
Good.
I was going to praise him.
[LAUGHTER]
So I just learned
something exciting.
First of all, we're going
to do curriculum and video
and helps for homeschoolers.
We're starting to
work on that now.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm ignorant.
And so I never heard of this.
But in Hillsdale,
Michigan, there's a co-op,
and that's a bunch
of homeschool moms.
They're mostly faculty moms, by
the way, that teach part-time
at the college, some of them.
And they get together and
they form a little school
with the kids in their families.
And now I've just learned
that I have another employee.
I'm going to hire her husband,
too, I decided the other day.
And they're in a group of
50 in Jackson, up the road.
So don't you see?
I think-- here's
my excited idea--
that's in fact what
all schools used to be.
People with the will, who
are reasonably intelligent,
can build and run
a great school.
If they get help, it's
better, and we help them.
But there's no reason,
in K through 12--
let's say, K through 9--
there's no real
reason why you need
an administration in a school.
And at Hillsdale, we find
that the homeschoolers--
first of all, it's hard
to get in to Hillsdale,
so the success
rates are very high.
Back when there was more
failure than there is now,
the homeschoolers stood out
because they never failed.
And why?
I think one of the challenges
when you get to college
is there's a lot more
work and it's harder,
and you've got to
concentrate for longer.
And homeschoolers are mostly
taught by mom, and she's busy.
They have to learn
on their own a lot.
And I think that's
good for them.
Yeah, and so I encourage
that very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Please join
me in thanking Dr. Arnn.
[APPLAUSE]